in 2008
kosovo became europe's newest country
this small state of 1.8 million people
emerged as a result of one of europe's
most brutal sectarian conflicts
since the second world war it was a
conflict that pitted an authoritarian
nationalist leader
slobodan milosevic when bombing top
then it will be very easy to continue
political process
against western military power we must
not allow
ethnic cleansing or genocide
particularly
at the edge of europe today kosovo is
peaceful but poor
crossover didn't only transition from
war to peace it was transitioned now
from
communist country to a capitalist one
from a
ravaged countryside to the one being
rebuilt
kosovo was part of serbia from 1912.
then in 1918 serbia became part of what
would become
yugoslavia serbs considered and say
that kosovo was there jerusalem it was
the sort of heart
of serbia to this day kosovo is still
divided along ethnic lines
over 90 percent of its population are
ethnic albanians
who are mostly muslim serbs
who are orthodox christians account for
about five percent
this is the southern city of pristina
capital of kosovo province
throughout the 1980s kosovo enjoyed
autonomy within serbia
but the majority ethnic albanian
population wanted more political freedom
because of albanian nationalism uh was
growing there were demands that kosovo
become
a republic kosovo cells began to
complain uh
saying that they were threatened but
there was one man standing in the way of
kosovo albanians
slobodan milosevic the leader of the
serbian communist party
milosevic wanted to keep kosovo as part
of serbia
he rallied the minority serb population
and further divided kosovo
sloboda milosevic used the kosovo serb
issue
to take power and to play the
nationalist card which was to propel him
to full power within serbia
in 1989 milosevic became president of
serbia
and within weeks placed kosovo back
under the direct control of his serbian
government
pedric salimi was growing up in kosovo
at the time
he and his family belong to the ethnic
albanian majority
when milosevic came to power we lost our
status our political rights were lost
our economic freedoms were lost and our
education
rights were lost as communism collapsed
across central and eastern europe
yugoslavia began to disintegrate from
1991 its republics declared independence
wars broke out in slovenia croatia and
bosnia as ethnic
serbs living in these new countries
opposed independence
milosevic wanted to carve a greater
serbia out of the ruins
so he sent his troops to support serbs
in these conflicts
during this turbulent time kosovo's
political leadership declared
independence
too but this was ignored by serbia and
the international community
in the late 1990s a guerrilla group the
kosovo liberation army
or kla began to attack serbian police
units
its aim was to win independence through
force
it was a mixture of excitement but fear
that something big is about to unfold
milosevic sent more serbian security
forces into kosovo to defeat the kla
the serbian security forces and yugoslav
army were pretty brutal
i mean the kla was quite brutal as well
but the overwhelming
uh proponents of force of course was on
the side of the serbian security
forces
on january the 15th 1999
serb forces attacked the village of
rachak killing 45
kosovo albanian civilians
rashik massacre was a turning point
because as soon
as the massacre unfolded people were
there western journalists
observers seeing the dead bodies and
calling
it what it was a crime against humanity
as serbian forces retook territory from
the kla
thousands of kosovo albanians fled their
homes
the images shocked the us
at a peace conference in france western
powers gave
serbia and kosovo albanians an ultimatum
accept a peace deal or face military
action
we're not interested in a partial
agreement we're interested in a
settlement that works
the serbs rejected the deal we are not
talking to
albanians we are talking to americans
who would like to take our territory for
themselves and for nato
and albanians were just excused for that
nato resolved to punish milosevic and
his army
and began air strikes on serb military
targets in kosovo
and throughout serbia itself it is about
creating the kind of world where an
innocent people are not
singled out for repression for expulsion
for destruction just because of their
religious
and ethnic heritage
during the war my parents my brother
fled
the neighborhood were kicked out by the
prayer militaries
they were hiding in the forest i didn't
know for several days are they alive or
not
after 78 days of bombing and hundreds of
civilian deaths
serbia capitulated milosevic withdrew
his forces from kosovo
nato tanks rolled in and patriot was
reunited with his family
as kosovo albanians returned tens of
thousands of ethnic serbs fled
north to serbia
it would be another nine years before
kosovo finally declared independence
today kosovo has a rough and ready
democracy
and a growing economy but unemployment
is high
at 33
in recent years clashes caused by ethnic
tension have erupted on occasions
today most kosovo serbs consider
themselves citizens of serbia they don't
recognize the kosovo state and they
don't
feel a part of it external pressure
could improve those strained relations
both kosovo and serbia are working to
join the european union
i don't think either of us will be able
to join the european family
until we sort out the issues with each
other dialogue
is the only way we can move forward
if kosovo and serbia are to become
eu member states their governments and
peoples will have to work together
and bury their bloody past
[Music]
you